Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özbolo. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Arztdienstarztätik.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen heute ein Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Gerne, bitte schön.
Als erstes benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten. Dann können wir weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Thomas Weber.
Thomas Weber. Könnten Sie bitte Vor- und Nachname langsam und deutlich beschreiben?
Vorname ist T-H-U-M-A-S. Nachname ist W-I-B-E-R.
Vielen Dank. Herr Weber, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 1971 geboren.
1971 geboren. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 14. Mai.
14. Mai. Okay, vielen Dank. Herr Weber, wie hoch sind Sie?
Wie groß?
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 Meter groß.
1,80 Meter groß. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 80 Kilogramm.
Ungefähr 80 Kilogramm. Okay, ich habe das nicht. Herr Weber, was für Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Also ich bin heute hier, weil ich extrem müde bin, Schwindel habe und manchmal auch mittlerweile Luftnot habe, wenn ich mich sehr stark belaste.
Schwindel müde und haben Sie Luftnot?
Wenn ich mich belaste, habe ich mittlerweile auch Luftnot. Das Ganze hat vor drei Wochen angefangen ungefähr.
Ja, vor drei Wochen angefangen. Okay. Haben Sie Brustschmerzen und Engelgefühl momentan?
Nein.
Sie haben schon gesagt, können Sie bitte wiederholen, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Das Ganze hat angefangen vor drei Wochen.
Drei Wochen.
Aber es wird jetzt immer schlimmer.
Schlimmer geworden. Mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Ganz genau.
Herr Weber, wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen? Sticheln, brennen, dumpf?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Ja, keine Schmerzen.
Nur Luftnot.
Ich habe Müdigkeit, Schwindel und mittlerweile auch etwas Luftnot, wenn ich mich stark belaste.
Herr Weber, gibt es ähnliche Beschwerden, die gleichzeitig sind? Zum Beispiel Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Mein Puls ist etwas schneller geworden als sonst.
Außer vor drei Wochen haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden erlebt?
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich so etwas habe.
Das war das erste Mal.
Herr Weber, in der letzten Zeit haben Sie Schlafstörungen oder?
Nein.
Keine Schlafstörungen.
Beim Schlafen, wie viele Kissen benötigen Sie?
Ich kann gut schlafen.
Gut schlafen?
Normal.
Gibt es etwas, das Beschwerden versteckt oder das schwindet? Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Ja, wenn ich mich belaste, habe ich mehr Luftnot und wenn ich mich anstrengen, habe ich etwas Schwindel.
Etwas Schwindel.
Wie beschreiben Sie diese Schwindel auf Karussel oder?
Nein, Schwangschwindel, wie auf einem Schiff.
Ja, auf dem Boot. Schwangschwindel.
Herr Weber, haben Sie Übelkeit, Erbrächen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Herr Weber, werden diese Beschwerden Ihrem Hausarzt besucht oder?
Nein, noch nicht.
Das war das erste Mal.
Dagegen haben Sie schon etwas, ein Medikament, angenommen?
Nein.
Herr Weber, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, kein Fieber.
Übelkeit und Erbrächen haben Sie schon getragen?
Nein.
Und Sie schlafen sehr gut, keine Schlafstörungen?
In der Nacht haben Sie Luftnot und Atemnot bemerkt oder?
Ich habe die Luftnot nur, wenn ich mich belaste.
Nur belasten.
Herr Weber, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Probleme nicht, nein, aber der ist von der Farbe etwas verändert.
Farbe verändert. Was haben Sie bemerkt beim Stuhlgang?
Er ist sehr dunkel geworden.
Dunkel geworden. Seit wann haben Sie das bemerkt?
Seit ungefähr zwei Wochen jetzt.
Ja, zwei Wochen.
Wie sagt der Stuhl?
Wie bitte?
Wie sagt der Stuhl? Nur dunkel oder gibt es zum Beispiel Blut?
Der ist sehr dunkel.
Okay, nur dunkel.
Haben Sie momentan Verstopfung oder Durchfall?
Der Stuhlgang ist eigentlich normal, nur die Farbe ist verändert. Der ist sehr dunkel.
Nur die Farbe verändert? Seit zwei Wochen haben Sie schon das bemerkt?
Ungefähr, ja.
Herr Weber, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay. Herr Weber, bleiben Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich habe Bluthochdruck. Ich nehme Bluthochmedikamente auch ein.
Bluthochdruck. Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Blutdruck habe ich schon seit ungefähr fünf Jahren jetzt.
Ungefähr fünf Jahre unter Kontrolle?
Genau, ich nehme ein Medikament ein, ja.
Okay, welches Medikament haben Sie?
RamiPril nehme ich ein.
Wie bitte?
RamiPril.
RamiPril. Wie viel Milligramm?
Fünf Milligramm, einmal morgens.
Einmal morgens. Gibt es noch etwas?
Ja, ich nehme auch Ibuprofen ein momentan.
Ibuprofen?
Ja.
Bei Bedarf oder nehmen Sie Regenmässig?
Nein, ich muss regelmäßig nehmen aktuell. Zweimal am Tag.
Warum haben Sie Regenmässig?
Ich habe momentan sehr starke Rückenschmerzen.
Rückenschmerzen.
Ich habe einen bekannten Bandscheibenvorfall. Und deswegen muss ich das nehmen.
Ich habe einen Beinscheibenvorfall.
Seit wann haben Sie die Ibuprofen regelmäßig angenommen?
Ja, ich nehme das jetzt schon ungefähr fünf bis sechs Wochen ein.
Fünf oder sechs Wochen. Es hat Ihnen geholfen, oder?
Ja, das hilft. Das hilft.
Ok. PromiPril, Ibuprofen und haben Sie noch andere mitgenommen?
Das war es.
Als bekannte Erkrankung seit fünf Jahren haben Sie Bluthochdruck und Rückenschmerzen wegen eines Bandscheibenvorfalls.
Genau.
Herr Weber, wissen Sie, wo ist Ihr Bandscheibenvorfall?
Der ist in der Ländenwirbelsäule.
Ländenwirbelsäule.
Und Herr Weber, würden Sie schon mal operieren, oder?
Nein, ich würde noch nicht operieren.
Keine Operation. Geschichte.
Herr Weber, haben Sie etwas bemerkt nach der Ibuprofen-Einnahme?
Zum Beispiel Zottrennen.
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Magen schwören oder...
Magen was?
Was?
Magen schwören oder Bauchschmerzen?
Schwören? Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Keine Schmerzen. Ok.
Herr Weber, wann waren Sie letztes Mal bei Ihrem Hausarzt?
Vor ungefähr drei Monaten war ich da.
Drei Monate. Da haben Sie etwas Problem?
Nein, es ging um meinen Blutdruckdruck.
Um die Medikamente.
Das war ganz normal.
Genau. Mein Blutdruck ist aber jetzt etwas niedriger als sonst.
Haben Sie auf Ihrem Haut oder bei den Augen etwas bemerkt?
Zum Beispiel Blaspa oder Hautveränderung oder...
Etwas blass bin ich geworden, ja.
Ein bisschen blass.
Nicht blass, blass.
Blass, ja.
Entschuldigung.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Befunde bemerkt?
Welche Befunde?
Blass, Hautblass.
Ja, auch jetzt ungefähr seit einer bis zwei Wochen ungefähr.
Eine Woche vielleicht ungefähr, ja.
Eine Woche. Ok. Herr Weber, haben Sie Allergie?
Ich habe keine Allergie, nein.
Noch etwas Unverträglichkeit oder?
Nein.
Und haben Sie schon mit Ibuprofen noch einen Magenschutz befunden oder?
Ich habe keinen Magenschutz.
Ok. Haben Sie keine Allergie und keine Unverträglichkeit?
Herr Weber, sind Sie vorgeimpft?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Gegen Corona auch?
Nein.
Herr Weber, in der letzten Zeit haben Sie im Ausland gereist oder?
Nein, ich war die ganze Zeit hier in Deutschland.
Herr Weber, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Einmal, zweimal im Monat, ja.
Ein, zweimal im Monat. Was trinken Sie?
Meistens Bier.
Inwieviel?
Kommt drauf an. Also wenn ich mit Freunden unterwegs bin, dann trinken wir gerne.
Ok. Herr Weber, bitte nehmen Sie nicht diese Frage persönlich. Haben Sie einmal Drogen konsumiert oder?
In meiner Jugend habe ich gemacht, aber jetzt mache ich nichts mehr.
Bei jungen Jahren?
Genau.
Aber schon lange Zeit nicht mehr Kontakt?
Nein, nämlich nicht mehr.
Herr Weber, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja.
Ihr Vater ist gesund?
Ja, der hat auch Bluthochdruck, Diabetes, der hat auch Herzprobleme.
Und bei der Mutter?
Mama ist eigentlich gesünder. Die nimmt aktuell keine Medikamente ein.
Super, super. Gott sei Dank. Gute Hürde. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Eine Schwester. Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist gesund.
Gott sei Dank, sehr gut. Und Herr Weber, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin ledig.
Ledig. Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Weber?
Ich bin Dachdecker.
Dachdecker.
Letzte Frage, Herr Weber. In der letzten Zeit, in zwei oder drei Wochen, haben Sie sich schon mal verletzt oder?
Nein.
Ok, sehr gut. Herr Weber, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig. Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich, oder?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ok. Ich habe den Verdacht auf Anämie.
Was ist das?
Daenblutung.
Daenblutung?
Ja.
Anämie bedeutet Daenblutung?
Nein, das ist nicht gleich.
Ich habe Anämie nicht verstanden. Was bedeutet Anämie?
Ja, ok. Ich habe den Verdacht auf Blutahmen.
Blutarmut?
Ja, Blutarmut, ja.
Ok.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung. Sollen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen?
Ich werde Ihnen als erstes körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen und dann Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Und dann einen Bauchultraschall möchte ich durchführen.
Und dann, sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, komme ich Ihnen zurück und dann erzähle ich Ihnen alles.
Ok, alles klar.
Dann werden Sie hier warten und dann komme ich Ihnen wieder zurück.
Ok.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Ich möchte etwas fragen. Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Wurde gefragt, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Wasser?
Wurde gefragt, normal.
Haben Sie ihn in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, gleich verblieben. Gute Frage.
Fertig?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie Gerohtete oder Geschwollen dabei?
Nein.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Wie bitte?
Bitte schön.
Ja, wann haben Sie in der Säule Ihren Blutdruck gemessen?
Den Blutdruck habe ich heute Morgen gemessen. Der war niedrig.
Wie hoch war er?
Der war 160.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen oder Palpitationen?
Ich weiß nicht, was Palpitationen sind, aber mein Puls schlägt etwas schneller.
Palpitation habe ich nicht verstanden.
Herzschlag.
Ich habe einen Herzschlag. Oder was meinen Sie?
Herzstolpern meinen Palpitationen.
Herzstolpern habe ich nicht.
Herr Weber, haben Sie in letzter Zeit in Ihrem Hals Schwellung behalten?
Nein.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Noch einmal bitte.
Die Farbe des Stühls ist schwarz. Wir haben es so gesagt, oder?
Genau. Sehr dunkel.
Haben Sie häufig Nasenbluten?
Nein.
Entschuldigung, mit welcher Dosierung nehmen Sie Ibuprofen ein?
600 Min. morgens und abends.
Wie ernähren Sie sich? Vegetarisch oder normal?
Normal.
Ich habe eine Frage stellen. Haben Sie Ohrensausen?
Nein.
Haben Sie ungewöhnliche Gelüste, zum Beispiel auf Eis oder Erde?
Haben Sie bestimmte Auslöse bemerkt für diese Extremmüdigkeit oder Schwindelkeit, für Ihre Beschwerden?
Leider nicht. Deswegen bin ich heute hier.
Okay, ja.
Ist Ihre Bandscheibenvorfall diagnostiziert seit wann?
3 Jahren.
Seit 3 Jahren. Okay. Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Haben wir besprochen. 5 Jahre.
5 Jahre, okay.
Haben Sie Haarausfall oder berühmte Nägel bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay, fangen wir an, Arzt-Arztgespräch.
Kann ich vorstellen? Meine Frage?
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Müssten Sie mich aufnehmen oder nicht aufnehmen?
Ja, möchte ich diese Patientin aufnehmen.
Ich meine, auf Video aufnehmen.
Ja.
Kann ich das aufnehmen?
Ich möchte nicht.
Sie sind aufgehört.
Ja. Wir haben sie aufgehört.
Auf dem Weg nach Leuert.
Sie können weiter gehen.
Okay.
Leuert.
Dann kann ich es machen.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, möchte ich Ihnen vorstellen.
Gerne, bitte schön.
Es geht um Thomas Weber.
Er ist 55 Jahre alt.
Er ist ein Jahr alt.
Er wurde am 14.05.1971 geboren.
Er ist 1,80 Meter groß und 80 Kilo.
Er stellt sich heute auf unsere Wege.
Er hat seit drei Wochen bestehende Prognosen.
Er hat eine Müdigkeit und Schwindel vor.
Er erwartete die Beschwerden.
Er hat vor drei Wochen langsam aufgetreten.
Im Laufe der Zeit wurde er schlimmer.
Er hat momentan Müdigkeit und Schwindel ausgeprägt.
Die Beschwerden werden sich bei Belastung verstärkt.
Laut Angaben der Patienten ist die Schwindel genau wie Schwachschwindel.
Er hat die Beschwerden in den letzten drei Wochen schlimmer.
Er beschreibt noch bei der Vegetative Anamnese
eine belastende Luftnot.
Er hat einen schweren Herzklopfen.
Er wurde verneint.
Die Vegetative Anamnese ist bis auf Schlafstörungen unaufwendig.
Bei der Vorerkrankung Anamnese
hatte er seit fünf Jahren Hypertonin.
Seit acht Wochen hat er einen Rückenschmerz wegen eines Bandscheibes.
Er hat keine Voroperationsgesichten.
Er nimmt täglich 5 mg Ramibri.
Seit acht Wochen nimmt er täglich 600 mg Ibuprofen.
Er ist morgens und abends ohne Protonpomphemah.
Bei ihm ist keine Allergie bekannt.
Er wurde voll geimpft.
Er hat in der letzten Zeit keine Reisegerichtssicht.
Er ist nicht raucher.
Er hat eine hohe Beatmischung.
Er hat einen weniger geringen Drogenkonsum.
Bei der Familienanamnese
hat er eine Erkrankung von Hypertonin,
Diabetes mellitus und Herzkrankheit.
Bei der Mutter ist er gesund.
Sie ist kein Einzelkind.
Er ergab sich sozialanamnistisch.
Er ist ledig, kein Kind.
Er ist Dachdecker.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf
magendere Blutung wegen
nonnichtsteroide Antireumatik.
Er hat eine Differenzialdiagnostik.
Differenzialdiagnostik.
Aber Cholestitis.
Nein.
Differenzialdiagnostik.
Er hat Magenkarzinom.
Ja.
Er hat auch unentzündliche Darmerkrankungen.
Wo vermuten Sie die Blutung?
Ich vermute, dass die Blutung
bei dem Magen entsteht.
Wegen nichtsteroide Antireumatik.
Genau.
Der Patient benutzt ohne Proton Opa Hema.
Er beschreibt noch eine
Farbveränderung.
Wie nennt man das?
Melena.
Der Stuhl.
Genau.
Vielleicht weiß der Patient gar nicht,
dass man das der Stuhl nennt.
Melena nennt.
Müdigkeit seit 3 Wochen.
Das entspricht einer Magen-Darm-Bluetung.
Eine Anämie.
Passen Sie die noch mal zusammen.
Sie denken, der Patient hat eine Anämie.
Eine Anämie.
Aufgrund von?
Aufgrund von nichtsteroide Antireumatik.
Nein.
Ein chronischen Blutverlust.
Bei oberer gastrointestinaler Blutung.
Aufgrund von NSAR-Einnahme.
NSAR-Einnahme.
Genau.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten jetzt?
Als erstes würde ich
diese Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Und Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Bei der Labor Blutbild.
Leber und Nierenwerte.
CAP.
Entzündungwerte.
Und Cholastasewerte.
Ein Übel- und Stuhlstatus.
Dann einen Bauchultraschall.
Das möchte ich gerne durchführen.
Und gegebenenfalls einen CT.
Aber erst mal
würde ich einen
gastroenthalogeischen
Konzil antworten.
Ich empfehle für diese Patienten
eine Ösafago-Gastrodendoskopie.
Richtig. Keine Darmspiegelung.
Keine Darmspiegelung.
Keine.
Und erst ÖGD.
Warum? Weil wir vermuten
die Blutung im Magen.
Nicht im Darm.
Deswegen richtig.
Wir haben das richtig gesagt. ÖGD.
Der erste Massnahme ist ÖGD.
Und dann Bauchultraschall.
Haben Sie gesagt schon, ja.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Medikamente geben Sie ihm was? Oder geben Sie ihm Blut?
Als Initialtherapie würde ich gerne
als Initialtherapie würde ich gerne
für diesen Patienten
eine Füßigkeit vor.
Und eine Lextrolytik-Substitution.
Am Ende eine Nahrungskarenz.
Oder einen Füßigkost verabreden.
Dann ein PPI-Protonpumper-Hämmer.
Weiter einfügen.
Oral oder intravenös?
Intravenös.
Genau.
Bei der Station aufnehmen.
Intravenös.
Protonpumper-Hämmer verabreichen.
Dann gegebenfalls
eine Spasmole-Zukung verabreichen.
Okay.
Warum?
Wenn die Patientin
eine Beschwerden hat,
könnte sie...
Also sie hat keine Schmerzen.
Ja, keine Schmerzen brauchen wir nicht.
Dann brauchen wir das nicht, ja?
Und als konservative Therapie
nach der Regede,
wenn es aktive Blutung gibt,
könnte bei der Endoskopie
ich würde sagen
Bandligation oder
Sklerogen-Injektion
in der Magenzine
oder in der Schmerzen
oder in der Injektion.
Also die Blutung stillen.
Man muss die Blutung stillen.
Er hat wahrscheinlich eine Blutung
im Magen und die muss man stillen.
Stillen. Okay, vielen Dank für die Information.
Wir haben keine diese Information.
Und gegebenfalls, wenn es
benötig ist, ja natürlich
man kann Bluttransfusion denken.
Richtig, ganz genau.
Wenn es benötig ist.
Aber muss man nicht. Wenn die Anämie noch normal ist,
dann muss man das nicht unbedingt machen. Sehr gut.
Wie viel PPI geben Sie denn?
Protonenpumpen in die Vitoren?
Normalerweise Standarddosis ist 40 Milligramm.
Ja.
Das ist täglich einmal.
Jetzt um Krankenhaus?
Bei der Intravenues Therapie
2x 20 Milligramm könnte sein.
Oder 2x 40 Milligramm.
Genau.
Und was machen Sie noch?
Der nimmt ja
Ibuprofen ein.
Das muss stoppen.
Genau. Muss gestoppt werden.
Wenn es nötig ist,
wegen Rückenschmerzen
oder Band-
Scheibevorfall.
Ohne, außer nicht steroide
Anti-Rheumatik.
Alternative Schmerztherapie?
Oder
Paracetamina?
Muss man auch eine Darmspiegelung machen?
Muss man oder muss man nicht?
Am akutem Fall,
ich dachte,
ÖGD, Gasodeodontoskopie
gleichzeitig machen können. Aber?
Ja, also man sagt immer,
es reicht erst mal ein ÖGD. Wenn Sie wissen,
der Patient blutet aus dem Magen,
dann müssten Sie keine ÖGD machen.
Aber wenn Sie sehen, Sie sehen keine Blutungsquelle,
dann müssten Sie eine Darmspiegelung machen.
Ja, mit keiner Blutungsquelle
sollen wir weiter gucken.
Genau. Sehr gut.
Ok, vielen Dank. Super. Vielen Dank.
Gibt es noch Fragen? Alles verstanden?
Gibt es Ergänzungen?
Ibuprofen, Einnahme in Selbstmedikation oder
arstliche Verbrechen? Ja, wurde nicht gefragt.
Wissen wir nicht. Kann sein vom Arzt.
Die Orthopäden geben gerne
Ibuprofen ohne Magenschutz.
Deswegen, es kann sein,
dass er auch selber einnimmt, wenn er zu Hause noch Medikamente hat.
Wurde nicht gefragt.
Wahrscheinlich hat er selber einnommen.
Herr Oberhaus, ich habe eine Frage.
Wann können wir Magenspiegelung
in diesem Fall durchführen?
Am besten sofort.
Wenn man guckt, dass man den Magen
erst mal leer bekommt.
Entschuldigung, ich habe falsch gesagt.
Daumenpielung muss man nicht machen.
Wenn Sie die Blutungsquelle
erhaut haben, also wissen, warum er blutet,
dann müssen Sie nicht unbedingt eine Darmspielung machen.
Aber Sie können ein, zwei Tage später,
wenn Sie möchten, können Sie das machen zu weiteren Diagnostik.
Muss man aber theoretisch gesehen nicht.
Wir müssen nur die Magenblutung stillen.
Dann wird der Hemoglobin wieder steigen.
Als Vorbeugung, Untersuchung,
wann wurde es empfohlen in Deutschland?
Nach 50 Jahren,
alle 10 Jahre einmal?
Oder gibt es andere?
Erstmal genau.
Also nicht Magenspiegelung, Darmspielung.
Magenspiegelung ist keine Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Nur Darmspiegelung ab 50.
Nur Darmspiegelung ist keine Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Nur Koloskopie.
Okay, alle verstanden.
Keine Fragen mehr. Alles einfach.
Sehr gut. Vielen Dank.
Dann haben Sie gut gemacht, Herr.
Das ist klasse. Sehr gut.